flowers trigger seasonal allergies
that's actually not true if you have a
hypoallergenic pet you won't have an
allergic reaction unfortunately there is
no such thing as a hypoallergenic pet
you can outgrow your seasonal allergies
so there's no definite way that you can
outgrow your seasonal allergies my name
is dr weiwei lee i am a board-certified
adult and pediatric allergy immunology
specialist my name is dr pail gupta and
i am also an adult and pediatric triple
board certified allergy asthma and
immunology doctor and today we'll be
debunking myths about allergies
if you didn't have allergies as a kid
you won't get them as an adult so that's
a myth you can actually develop
allergies at any point in your life
especially now with people moving to
different locations the change in
climate location or sometimes adopting a
new pet can increase your risk for
developing allergies right so it's any
new exposure essentially can cause your
system to start reacting and develop an
allergy i've also had at the reverse
i've also had people who have lived with
cats and dogs while they were children
and then they decide to get a cat or dog
as an adult and they're now allergic and
so your immune system is constantly
changing and so you can develop an
allergy at any time you should only take
allergy medication once you feel
symptoms so that is a myth so if you
wait until your symptoms get super
intense and super severe then it'll be
that much harder to get those symptoms
under control so it's a good idea to
start early like if you have pile
analogy in the spring i usually say have
the patients start pre-medicating with
anti-histamine nasal spray or eye drops
before the season starts i usually
recommend as soon as they start seeing
even a little bit of the pollen that
they're allergic to especially severe
seasonal allergy sufferers we have them
take them even two weeks in advance just
so they get used to taking them the
timing sometimes can change from year to
year depending on the weather so you can
use the timing from last year to make a
proximal guess to when you can start
pre-medication tree allergies are mostly
a springtime allergen grass allergies
are for summer and weed allergies are in
the fall so for people who have tree
grass and weed normally it would have
been maybe from like april until
september that they might have had
symptoms but now we're seeing even as
early as february especially
and then the weed allergen kind of
ending as late as october november and
patient asks us is it safe to take the
medication every day i would say if you
take the medication according to how we
recommend it it is safe and effective
and it's important to know that when you
take your medications such as a
combination of oral antihistamine and
nasal spray together every day achieve a
better efficacy than taking it
sporadically only when you have symptoms
flowers trigger seasonal allergies
that's actually not true pollens from
flowering plants are not the main
contributor to seasonal allergy symptoms
in order for pollen to cause allergic
symptoms they need to meet three
criteria they need to be small
they need to be light and they need to
be dry to be carried by wind so the
pollen and flowers is actually large and
it's distributed by insects and so
that pollen is not in the air which
means that it doesn't get into our eyes
and nose however for tree pollen weed
pollen and grass pollen because it's
light and because it travels in the air
more easily then
it can get into our eyes and nose and
airways more easily and because it
travels
at least around 50 miles that means it
might not be a tree in your backyard it
might be a tree somewhere far away that
you're reacting to but i do hear that
every year a patient coming and saying
that this is the worst allergy symptom
that i have compared to the past so i
think that has to do with a number of
factors such as
climate change and also planting
particular type of tree in certain
location can increase the symptoms
eating local honey can help cure
seasonal allergies
that is a myth because local honey
contains pollen collected by bees so
those come from flowering plants we
mentioned before pollen from flowering
plants are not major contributor to
seasonal allergies
and also we don't have a lot of studies
done on the effectiveness of local honey
so we cannot know for sure how effective
they are in treating or helping to cure
your seasonal allergy symptoms but i
love honey because i use that to help
with allergy symptoms such as ichi's
scratchy throat so i have no problem
recommending using honey as a way to
soothe your throat your symptoms but i
would not say
it can cure seasonal allergies she
nailed it hopefully i can do that every
time
if you have a hypoallergenic pet you
won't have an allergic reaction so
that's a myth so unfortunately there is
no such thing as a hypoallergenic pet a
lot of breeders will claim to have
hypoallergenic pets but unfortunately
there is no hundred percent animal
without any dander the pet tender is the
microscopic flex of skin that the pet
shed so the same protein can be also
found in their saliva so it's not the
fur but rather the the shedding of the
skin with their saliva it's important to
know that even hair less stock can shed
and that will contain some degree of
allergens and so there might be certain
breeds that people are less allergic to
and that's all person-dependent so for
example i have a cat allergy but there's
certain cats that i do totally fine
around and then there's other cats that
as soon as i walk into someone's home
and they have that cat i'll start
reacting and so it is not just by
touching or rubbing your face against
the cat the dander is airborne so that
can get into your eyes and nose and into
your airways and start causing that ige
antibody to react and produce that
histamine which causes the symptoms
frequent vacuuming is super important
also air purifiers and so
for somebody that really wants a pet or
you know usually it happens the other
way around is that they've already
gotten a pet and they're not willing to
get rid of it for those patients then we
usually do attempt to do allergy
immunotherapy and see how
well we can control their allergy
symptoms we don't have a test to test
for particulation
yeah we wish we did because if we did we
would have a huge long line out the door
of people wanting to get tested for
particular breeds that they might be
able to have in their home allergy shots
don't work so allergy shots are
immunotherapy and
allergy shots actually have a lot of
data behind them and they've been used
for years and years and we know that
they do reduce the not only the symptoms
that people experience but also the
medications that people are on and then
there's also the allergy sublingual
immunotherapy tablets that are fda
approved so there's two different
options and i just always like to
mention that because some people are
scared of shots i think there is this
myth because people will misunderstood
allergy shots as medication allergy
shots are not medications they don't
provide immediate symptomatic relief but
see them as a way to naturally
desensitize your allergens and to
naturally develop tolerance you will
still have to take your allergy
medications such as antihistamine or
nasal spray at the beginning of allergy
shots to help you manage your allergy
symptoms but over the long term allergy
shots do work to achieve that natural
tolerance you can outgrow your seasonal
allergies that is not true because with
your immune system changing sometimes
your symptom can get better or worse
over time so there's no definite way
that you can outgrow your seasonal
allergies sometimes people might have
moved from the west coast to the east
coast and all of a sudden they don't
have those seasonal symptoms that they
used to so they might say that oh i
outgrew my seasonal allergies but it's
really that they moved and that they're
not exposed to the same pollens that
they were when they were younger the
most frequent symptoms that we see are
symptoms of the eyes for example itchy
watery eyes
the nose can get congested you can have
a runny nose itchy nose you can have a
sore throat from post nasal drip and you
can also have coughing wheezing
shortness of breath if you have allergic
asthma currently the closest cure we
have for seasonal allergies is called
allergy immunotherapy i think the
important thing to remember with
immunotherapy is that you have to be
ready and committed for it for allergy
shots you will need to go into the
allergist office weekly for uh six to
nine months and then it goes to monthly
and we would say that you should
continue your therapy for at least three
to five years for it to be effective and
then for the sublingual immunotherapy
tablets it depends on which tablet
you're going to start for dust mite
immunotherapy tablets for example you
have to take it daily and we would also
recommend that you take them daily for
at least three to five years in order to
get the full benefit from them you can
cure your allergies so we can't cure
environmental or food allergies at this
time we've come pretty close to
environmental allergies but the reason
is is that we haven't figured out how to
definitively change the immune system's
reaction to environmental allergens or
to food allergens our environment
doesn't stay
the same all the time so with new
exposure in our environment
our immune system is constantly adapting
to the new triggers in the environment
so we can develop new allergies even if
we
cure the old allergies that's why i
don't like to use the word cure because
you can always develop new allergy
symptoms after going through
immunotherapy so once we have the
allergy test results we always want to
see what are your exposures knowledge is
power so once you know what your
triggers are there's a lot of things you
can do besides taking medications their
behavioral modification we always
provide to our patient education what to
do when you're allergic to certain
pollen what to do during pollen season
or what to do with pet dander dust mites
we can help you to manage your allergies